today President Trump is addressing the
crisis on our southern border and
calling for funding of the border wall
tweeting quote Republicans and Democrats
must come together finally with a major
border security package which will
include funding for the wall after 40
years of talk it's finally time for
action
fix the border for once and for all now
now the president's call for action
comes as over six thousand members of
the migrant caravan have reached the
Mexican border town of Tijuana and at
one point a small group of protesters
broke away from the caravan and got
within 500 feet of the US border and in
an interview released yesterday yet this
Hillary Clinton told the Guardian that
Europe needs to get a handle on
immigration to stop the growth of
right-wing populist Hillary says quote I
think it's fair to say Europe has done
its part and must send a very clear
message we are not going to be able to
continue to provide refuge and support
because if we don't deal with a
migration issue it will continue to roil
the body politic joining us now with
reaction is America first action senior
advisor and former Trump press secretary
Sean Spicer Fox News contributor Deroy
Murdoch and national Border Patrol
council vice president art Delk widow or
a good evening gentlemen thank you all
for being here you know I have to start
with hillary only because i always like
to start with hillary I mean did this
woman a did she have a lobotomy
why is she now saying we've got to tell
Europe they have to stop the migration
it's a royal - the body politic Sean
Spicer hit it I'm not sure if anyone's
listening to her that's the bigger issue
I don't know what I mean it's funny she
first she stands in the way of
immigration reform she does everything
she can to stop it if stopped dealing
with it in this country and yet she
wants to preach to Europe what they
should be doing and then somehow comes
up to those kooky responses somehow
because they've allowed all these people
into their borders had open border
policies that that's given rise to the
populist movement that created break
sit-in Trump I don't really even fully
appreciate what she's trying to get
through it sounds like a bunch of
gobbledygook to be honest with you
well you know in Deroy I personally was
shocked momentarily but then when I
thought it through I said to myself self
the truth is that she will change her
opinion she and Bill are notorious for
this based upon the way the wind blows
so it tells me one of two things that
you know she's a chameleon no absolutely
but secondly that she's willing to throw
the refugees to the Wolves because she
thinks it's helping the politics of her
opponent what does that tell you about
her well I mean it's very simply take
whatever argument she's making about
Europe and you apply here I mean if
we're gonna have this situation of chaos
with people breaking in from the
guatemalan guatemala tamale mexican
border and then breaking into our
borders well it's only gonna fuel people
who believe in what President Trump says
which is we have to have border security
and I just say look you know if that
argument applies in Europe to Europe it
definitely applies over here as well
all right she's consistent about it she
is that she is and aren't Oh quite quite
oh you are the man at the border tell us
what is going on there and tell us what
is wrong with the President of the
United States saying that if you want to
seek asylum come in the right way come
through a legal you know entrance
there's nothing wrong with what he's
saying judge the reality is we now have
a president that he's doing what no
other president has done and that's
pretty much making sure that our nations
are secure short of grabbing a gun and a
rifle and being at a point himself he's
done everything he can it's now up to
the Democrats and the Republicans to
come together and do the right thing and
help out with the bills that he's trying
to present and and I'll be honest it's
also it falls on the leadership within
the DHS and homeland security this is a
man that's on point and he's showing he
cares okay does it matter what side of
the aisle you're on you want security in
your borders oh you want security in
your home everyone locks their doors at
night okay but let me ask you this you
said something it comes down to
the leaders of homeland security and
that would be Kirsten Nielsen what is
she not doing right or what is she doing
wrong you know what I'm saying is they
need to get on the right path when you
have a president saying I need you to
stop catch and release and catch and
release has not stopped I think that's a
problem okay all right in Sean Spicer I
mean you were there when all this was
when you were in the White House with a
catch-and-release that we started with
the Obama administration what can the
president do about that especially in
light of this federal judge you know
every time he does something and we're
gonna talk about this in the next
segment you know you got a federal judge
willing to stop it but what about catch
and release how do we change that well I
think this president has actually
changed the entire dynamic because he's
made it very clear he's talked about
that they're gonna be stay in Mexico
apply for asylum there unless they can
prove that they're in imminent danger
he has upended all of the all of the
precedent that has gone on before this
and and taken away just the talk and the
rhetoric that we've gotten from so many
politicians and replaced it with action
this president I think has done as much
as he possibly can through executive
order inaction and through his
administration through DHS he truly does
need a partner in Congress in these
remaining days of this lame-duck
Congress to give him the funding that he
needs for a border wall and border
security in addition sorry you and I
both know they don't want to give him
the money for the wall I mean and I
blame Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell for
this they limited the actual building to
1.6 billion dollars is it 1.6 million
I think it's billion all right and in
the end I'll go to you to Rory I mean
the truth is that it you know the
party's not working with him and now he
says I want Republicans and Democrats
come together what leverage does the
president have he's talking about
shutting down the government I mean what
does he do a couple things one is he
could shut down the government second
thing I think once these guys come back
from Thanksgiving he should keep the
hundred fifteen Congress in up on
Capitol Hill until January 3rd when
Democrats come in and they should vote
vote vote vote vote and litter his desk
with legislation on immigration and
other things and the other message that
has to go out to all these people Russia
we want to rush across the border is if
you want to come to America do what my
mother and father did when they left
Costa
they went to the u.s. embassy and they
fill that visa applications fill out the
paperwork that's not too much to ask you
want to come to America
ring the front doorbell don't run in and
break in through the bathroom window
which is the approach these people are
taking now and you know when art art
when when jewelry talks about you know
ring the doorbell
you know we'll come in I mean our
country is our home that's right and you
know you I was a you referred to this
some people take objection when you call
it an invasion I don't know what what
the heck else to call it but you call
them all today Warren horn that was a
word that I hadn't heard why because
it's it's it's a huge group of people
from another country that are flying a
flag to enter our country that doesn't
look like people that are seeking asylum
it doesn't look like people that are you
know escaping persecution they're coming
here is an invasion plain and simple a
lot of it has to do with the economy you
know hey if you guys want to give credit
to President Trump then give him
president be given credit because of the
economy
that's one of the reasons they're coming
up here the reality is we have a
president that's doing everything he can
and everyone else needs to get on board
that's the bottom line
hey Jimmy all want to feel secure at
homes go ahead Shawn I will say that you
mentioned the beginning America America
first action in America first pack have
been in this fight with the president
Eyring ads putting out videos making
sure that the research is done but we're
gonna make sure that we do our part to
spread the word about what the
president's policies are doing and to
put pressure on Congress as we head into
these final days of this Congress well
yeah absolutely and you know one of the
things that I think is so important
right now is that Tijuana has actually
declared a humanitarian crisis and in
you know apparently as this caravans
been moving gentlemen they've stayed one
or two nights in a particular town and
so the town is happy to give them food
and give them you know a place to stay
but I think we're looking at the crisis
of you know Guatemala and Tijuana but
Tijuana in particular in addition to
some of the violence that we're seeing
you know they're saying look we need the
United Nations to come in this Caravan
is out of control go ahead and delay I
think also my question here is where is
it written that anybody has a right to
come in
you leave Honduras and you get to Mexico
you're entering country that's about
four times wealthier than Honduras is
and I'd say hey that's pretty
comfortable and the Mexican government
said we'll give you homes we'll give you
education we'll give you health care
right they ought to say hey this is
great we'll take that deal and their
attitude is basically like the stealing
and song whoa no Guadalajara won't do
and then here they come to Tijuana ready
to rush the border in the United States
again where do we have the obligation to
let them in especially with when they
don't ask permission to come in here
well there's no question it and and are
why are they not I'm gonna go right to
you but why are they not taking
advantage of what Mexico's offering them
because they don't want to they don't
want to because it's not it's not that
they're looking for asylum they're
looking to come into the United States
because they probably have jobs already
lined up here they probably have people
already here that are waiting for them
that's the reality they want to invade
our country they want to come in here
because there's no consequences for them
that's what it is and it's not a race
issue people need to get away from this
you're seeing the the mayor of Tijuana
and everything he's saying no one's
calling him a racist and yes President
Trump has said all the right things and
you turn around and you call it a racist
statement here it has nothing to do a
trace illegal is not a race illegals
simply illegal there's a right way to do
things in a wrong way to do things so
well said and you know Shawn I'm gonna
go to you you know one of the things
that I saw today was a video where one
of these caravan members is yelling open
the gates Trump we are looking to come
in we are looking for work and can you
imagine while they fly the flag of their
own country they say Trump open the
gates
I mean and god forbid you try to deport
them to that country they were waving
the flag on that's why they want to get
on our soil so they can immediately have
the constitutional rights
exactly look I think I think they
recognize the fact that this president's
created an amazing economy here in the
United States there's a ton of jobs
available and they see that they want to
come up here for the jobs but at the
same time the president's continued to
be tough on immigration he understands
that we have to have border security so
there's this catch-22 he's creating an
amazing economy where there's tons of
jobs to go around and people are using
that as a magnet to want to come into
this country but there the president
very clear we're still a country of
immigrants who are a welcoming country
but you have to do it legally and I
think that's where the where people have
to understand that the president wants
to have law and order he wants to have a
vibrant city continues to welcome people
but do so in an orderly way well the way
that they're supposed to anyway great
discussion Deroy Shawn and art sorry
next time we'll come back to